the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i want to show you what our old
friend george rr martin had to say
before hbo aired its first episode of
house of the dragon last night for those
of you who haven't seen it it looks like
he had one final message before the show
went out to millions of fans all over
the realm
let's head on over to george rr martin's
not a blog website so you can see what
he had to say he said the dragons are
here tonight's the night it has been
three years since game of thrones wound
up its run on hbo and way way longer
since we began the development of the
successor series that eventually became
house of the dragon you have been
reading all about it for days or weeks
or months depending on how much you
follow the news out of westeros me i've
done more interviews than i can count we
had a huge panel in hall h at san diego
comic con and red carpet events in los
angeles amsterdam london india sweden
and right here in santa fe at my cinema
there's an amazing 3d billboard in new
york city overlooking times square
there's more content on youtube than
anyone can keep track of archmaester
gildane's history fire and blood is back
on the bestseller list in climbing you
can get a signed copy from beastly books
reviews have been coming in most good
some bad i don't know what else i can
say except house of the dragon airs
tonight on hbo and hbo max
now what george actually says next makes
me think he might have been a little
excited and nervous about the first
episode finally airing on hbo he said
whatever happens from here my sincere
thanks go out to ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick to one of the most
astonishing casts it has ever been my
honor to work with an incredible crew to
an amazing writing staff to my friends
at hbo past and present who have worked
for years to bring hot d to fruition and
to the fans without whom none of this
would have happened and a tip of my cap
to my editors publishers and readers as
well it all began 40 odd years ago with
a book
watch the show i hope you'll enjoy it
now it's insane to actually think that
george rr martin began this story nearly
40 years ago when he first envisioned
the scene where the starks find their
direwolves in the late summer snows and
now we're here with many best-selling
novels later one massively successful
show in game of thrones arguably the
most successful show ever and now this
new show with house of the dragon it's
amazing to think how we're finally here
even after game of thrones had such a
divisive ending this fandom is so strong
there's still millions and millions of
fans like me and you who are ready for
more and then some
now the reason why i think he was a
little nervous is because of how he said
whatever happens from here he wants to
thank everyone who was involved with
making the show he knows that letting
the news outlets review the show early
is one thing but showing the first
episode and eventually the whole first
season to the entire world is something
entirely different i mean he knows
better than anyone if the fans do not
like house of the dragon they will not
be afraid to let him and everyone else
who worked on it know exactly how they
feel like i said in my video last night
i think they did a great job with the
first episode now it might not have had
one of those standout moments like the
white walkers reveal but it still did an
amazing job at introducing us to all of
these characters their relationships
with one another and their own conflicts
and desires i believe this show will
only get better from here on out if
you've read fire and blood you
definitely know about all the amazing
moments that are heading our way also in
another one of george rr martin's recent
interviews he said he will no longer
guess at when he will release the ones
of winter if you know his history then
you know he sucks at guessing whenever
he will finish his novels all it ends up
doing is making the fans even more angry
whenever he misses a deadline he said i
do find it a little grisly whenever fans
speculate online about what's gonna
happen to the rest of my novels after i
die i don't feel close to dying well
george if it means anything to you i do
hope that you live forever i also think
it's a little disrespectful whenever
fans discuss what might happen with the
winds of winter or even a dream of
spring when he dies
now that house of the dragon is finally
here how many of you would rather have
the ones of winter instead of the new
show if you actually did have the option
of having one or the other which one
would you want right now i am wondering
if house of the dragon's first episode
had any effect whatsoever on what the
fans actually want now i'm sure most of
the book readers would rather have the
ones of winter but i am wondering if it
even matters to those of you who haven't
read them let me know your thoughts down
below also i have a lot more videos that
i will be releasing this week if you
haven't already make sure you subscribe
so you're the first to know whenever i
release a new video i still have my full
breakdown in review on the way as always
i want to thank everyone for watching
this video i hope you all have a great
day i will see you again very soon bye
so
[Music]
you